foreign
[Music]
five years ago
I decided to learn more about two
exciting Frameworks that I kept hearing
about more and more often everywhere
really in bars restaurants it got really
spooky
the first is the art idiverse from
Hadley's and Garrett's great book Alpha
data science and some of you might have
heard of it maybe
and the second one is the kaggle machine
learning and data science platform
and little did I know at the time that
the combination of those Frameworks
would transform my career and open up a
whole new world of exciting challenges
and much like for our Dragon Ball
friends there this Fusion really boosted
my power level
so today I would like to show you
how the cargo Community can help you to
grow to learn and to inspire others
and whether you're a regular in kaggle
I've only ever dipped your toes into the
community or I've never heard of it at
all I hope that my talk and my story
will inspire you to make the most out of
the amazing opportunities that a Cairo
Community provides
and that in turn you will then share
your great ideas and creativity with the
rest of us
now that sounds great you might say
I have a very small question though
what is kaggle
well I'm glad you asked
kaggle.com was launched 13 years ago as
a website for machine learning
competitions
and that means that the goal is to build
competitive predictive models on a
specific machine learning problem with
the best models in the end scoring
highest on an objective leaderboard and
while competitions remain one of the
main cornerstones today cargo covers
many key aspects of the data science
landscape
users can upload and curate their own
data sets
Lively discussion forums host many
conversations about machine learning and
data science
and cagnas can build run and publish
their own notebooks directly on the site
and there's so much to learn here so
much to discover
but I also realized that all these
possibilities can be a little bit
confusing right maybe intimidating when
you're joining the site at first and I
get it I really do when I joined cargo
back in the day I felt the same I felt a
little bit hesitant when I saw all these
smart people and their clever ideas so
much so in fact that I decided to join
up anonymously under the pseudonym heads
or tails
nobody knew who I really was and that
helped to alleviate much of the pressure
that I would have otherwise put myself
under when it comes to actively
participating in the community
so with this little trick I felt free to
work my regular job during the day and
be on kaggle in my secret identity in
the evenings and well nights and but
what I quickly realized is that much
like the our community the kagga
community was exceptionally welcoming
and supportive of its new members and it
remained so to this day
the other trick that helped me was at
first to only focus on one aspect of
kaco rather than trying to do everything
at once and in my case I gravitated
towards the notebooks you see I'm a very
visual person and my academic background
had trained me to write coherent reports
and my goal on kaggle was to learn new
tools and new methods and I always
learned best when I can apply these new
tools on a practical problem
so it came natural to me to start
writing and Publishing notebooks to
learn and to share what I learned with
others
and so today my talk will be evolving
around the notebooks but much of what
I'm telling you can be translated to
kaggle's other aspects as well like
discussions or competitions also courses
which might be more relevant for you and
your goals
and all these aspects are representative
of kaggle as a whole and in turn they
also contain smaller areas that are
representative of them
so in a sense much like a cauliflower
this is a fractal approach and a fractal
talk
in which I would like to show you that I
can be less than just a one-dimensional
speaker
I'd take that
so I started learning the art ideas and
to write kaggle notebooks to practice
what I had learned
and I also started reading the notebooks
that other people were putting out
and that really exploded my horizons
there was so much creativity so many
great ideas out there to give you an
example
I remember when I first discovered this
notebook written by Jonathan in r on U.S
flight tracking data and I had never
worked with geospatial Data before in
his map visuals they just blew my mind
I had the way that he presented his
insights was so clean and well thought
out there's a lot going on in this map
that the different cities the flight
routes but the design choices make this
visual very clear and accessible
so I wanted to learn about geospatial
data and then this competition launched
which was about predicting taxi trip
durations in New York City but it was
really about writing notebooks that
other people would find useful
exploring the data breaking it down
finding all the hidden insights
so I took my exploratory approach and I
started to learn from scratch about maps
and and geocoordinates and all these
things and this is my very first
interactive leaflet map that I built for
this notebook that I wrote and I'm still
using leaflet today based on what I
learned from this experience it's a
great tool
and even better my notebook ended up
receiving the most Community votes in
this competition and winning me a prize
I was I was awesome I mean I was over
the moon
oh thank you thank you
[Applause]
and I had found my new passion
so over the following months I jumped
into almost every new competition that
was launched so that I could learn about
the specific tools that were needed to
understand the data
right and um
my goal was to be the first person to
write a comprehensive exploratory data
analysis for the competition data
so that when new people joined the
competition they could get a jump start
right so Eda became my focus and it
allowed me to discover and to share lots
of cool stuff so for instance I joined
the time series forecasting competition
to learn about methods like arima or
tools like profit and this particular
example was about predicting web views
for specific International Wikipedia
pages
so here in this example plot you see
that the views for the Wiki page of the
band 21 Pilots exploded dramatically in
early 2016. I don't really know them I
don't know why that happened but there
are some there's some interesting lag
effects here as to how this rise
happened in the different countries that
are coded by different colors and some
interesting lags and these spikes too
that pop up right so features like this
made this competition interesting and
challenging
and I also joined my first NLP
competitions learning how to use Julius
and David's great tidy tax package and
in this particular one I was flexing my
storytelling muscles and I wrote my own
chilling short story around the analysis
of language used by classic horror
writers like Shelley or Lovecraft right
so you see that Love and Death are there
at the center of most of these stories
intertwined in an eternal battle
and with every new notebook and every
new competition I was learning something
new new tools new tricks and new ideas
from meeting other people's notebooks
and exchanging Thoughts with them you
see one of the great things about kaggle
notebooks is that you can fork and tweak
them directly on the website using this
little button up there and you see this
often with competition modeling code
when people build on each other's models
and make them better step by step
the kaggle community is very good at
learning from each other and it's
standing on each other's shoulders to
see further than we otherwise could
and myself I owe a lot to the support of
the carrier Community which made me the
very first notebook's Grandmaster
which is a title that you can earn
through Community votes on your
notebooks and then you can take your
achievements and your work and you can
showcase it to the world through your
cargo profile for instance to recruiters
right so this is my profile which kind
of summarizes my top notebooks and data
sets and so on in a very comprehensive
way and I'm pretty positive that it
helped me a lot in my transition from
the Ivory Towers of Academia to doing
data science in the real world right and
a lot of the interviews that I had with
various companies the lessons that I had
learned on kaggle they were invaluable
and I'm sure the whole Grandmaster thing
didn't hurt either right it's like
but yeah so I believe that the use of
Cargill as a portfolio remains very
underrated even today it's a great way
to Showcase your work especially in
notebooks and I would really like to
encourage you to make your kaggle
notebooks public
I've read a lot of notebooks over the
last five years and virtually all of
them had something interesting that I
could learn and I felt very grateful
towards the authors
in fact
two years ago I decided to start an
initiative around the kaggle notebooks
so
let me tell you about my initiative
oh no no not that one
no no no no that's not the one either
oh man I'm dating myself with that
reference right that's it's been a while
um no what I'm talking about is an
initiative to discover and highlight
great cargo notebooks which for whatever
reason hadn't gotten the attention and
cudors from the community that they
deserve I'm calling them hidden gems
and after reading hundreds of notebooks
and writing quite a few myself I would
like to share with you what kaggle
taught me on how to write a great
notebook
right so here are a few tips that will
be illustrated by different hidden gems
so first of all you want to introduce
your work to capture your reader's
attention and draw them into your
analysis
a couple of topical images or
illustrations go always well with a few
opening paragraphs that explain the
goals the context and set the scene for
what's to follow so like Laura here you
could use an image of cocoa beans to
lead into your flavorful analysis of
chocolate taste readings
explaining your methodology will help
your reader to follow your analysis
through its various steps and this can
be part of your introduction and you can
even go as far as ramshanker did and
build a flowchart out of little
pictograms that explain the different
steps of your analysis and this is
really some Next Level methodology
communication right there
great visuals of course there are they
are at the heart of many Fantastic
notebooks and whether it's for
exploration or for communication you
want your data visualizations to be
clear and accessible in communicating
the insights that you derived
and that can mean simple visuals but it
can also mean complex but well designed
so in this example here Daniel
was creating a visual for climate models
and Rising CO2 levels that would not
look out of place in a science or nature
paper on some high profile website right
that's meticulously designed with insets
and annotations and definitely takes a
little time to digest so like with all
of them if you want to learn more
definitely check out the notebook
but visuals themselves are not enough
right you also want to document your
findings and what you read in those
visuals not just for your audience but
also for yourself so that if you come
back to your notebook maybe six months
later you will thank past you for
writing down what was so interesting
about these plots that you made
right and parole here demonstrates this
very well with her points to note
complete with a little pictogram as a
visual anchor
and documentation is of course the
cousin of narration so you always want
to have a nice narrative flow that leads
your Reader through your analysis from
one step to another
as my final tip for today at least you
can take your visualizations and
exploration from the exploration of data
to the explanation of models
in one of the most outstanding hidden
gems Jack here was charting the Journey
of an image through a neural network
which is a fantastic Title by the way
titles are important too
but what I wanted to focus on is the way
in which he uses the data visualizations
to show how this handwritten digit gets
transformed through the different layers
of the neural network all the way down
to the classification layer and what
happens in between
right so if you want to learn more about
deep learning or if you just want to
read something really cool check out
Jack's notebook that's great
so some of you might have noticed that
all of these examples that I showed you
for hidden gems were from python
notebooks
as a bit of a contrast to the earlier
our notebooks that I showed and today
python is definitely the most popular
language on kaggle especially for deep
learning applications but there's still
plenty of great R content around in 300
Hidden gems that I collected so far I
found that the ratio was three quarters
of the notebooks were in Python and one
quarter in r
and it shouldn't stop you if a notebook
is in Python right you can still learn a
lot from it in fact one neat way of
learning might be to take the ideas from
a python notebook and translate them
into R right or vice versa
that might be a good way for you to get
started on kaggle
but for the closing thought of this talk
I might have an even better way for you
to start your own kaggle Journey
because I've put together a kaggle data
set specifically for this conference and
it contains the names of all the
packages that are currently on Crown
together with quite a bit of their
metadata and all their release history
so there are quite a few features in
there that uh could be interesting for
our users and you could start digging
into these features directly on the
website by pressing this button there
which will create a new notebook it will
get you to an editor and you can start
analyzing the data right there on the
website
so I would like to invite you to go to
the data set page for instance by
scanning this handy QR code that's there
in corner
open up a new notebook and start your
very own kaggle Journey right here right
today
and I will be looking forward to see all
the great ideas and creativity that you
would bring in
I would love to Welcome All of You
to the cargo community and right now I
welcome your questions thank you
thank you